I'm in Morocco North Africa to discover
the hidden culinary secrets of this
incredible country I've always loved
Moroccan food because every bite is
steeped in history over the centuries
the Arabs Spanish ottomans and French
have all left their mark on the cuisine
of the indigenous Berber people my
journey of discovery begins in Fez
Northwest Morocco the country's culinary
capital located on the edge of the
middle Atlas Mountains the medina of fez
is one of the oldest walled cities in
the world it feels like I've been
transported back in time incredible and
beautiful and confusing all the same
freaking time man sir
this place is like a labyrinth versus
crazy
there's over 9000 alleyways and I think
I've been down everyone the most
confusing maze ever I'm supposed to be
meeting one of Morocco's finest chefs
now Jack cannot swore not Jesse pebble I
am lost
but finding our rendezvous points is
proving trickier than I expected okay
I'm pretty sure this is the spot oh no
Jack cannot is one of a small band of
pioneering female chefs changing the
face of Moroccan cuisine after earning
her stripes at a string of michelin star
establishments across Europe and America
her own restaurant in the heart of the
medina is already gaining quite a
reputation the first thing I thought
about what would it be like to have a
restaurant here we're always product on
your doorstep do you ever get lost down
here there you get lost in this medina
barefoot so imagine that's me it's so
nice to meet you now I'm dying to get
really underneath this incredible Asus
can you lead the way cuz I'm useless
okay
straight up thank you place is crazy
Nijat tells me this has been a food
market since the ninth century this is
the flavors here just the colors the
colors you know Sheila's are you two
waiting for hotness I understand I'm too
white for hotness did you just say that
delicious pretty good thank you
amazing you like to speak French oh wait
this is the butter I need you to smell
Monty how did a woman you know the
French people think that I invented
pillow yes
that's not finger I know this is not
fellow this is worker okay right okay
it looks like my grandma's curtains so
is it a flower dies beautiful I think
you should go inside and try for that
and now I'm going to correct you because
I'm allowed to do that one will you tell
her I'm a cookie in English you look at
me like I'm an idiot
now let's go
you have to stretch it without crushing
Bravo she says it's so wonderful to see
you do this yes when the job finally
stops laughing at me I managed to finish
my pastry may I started I'm bringing in
here yeah
so now hello now you have to be careful
when it cooks you gotta bring it up
thank you so much
he's what I would say Allah Nancy but
cool man it's a lot harder than it looks
let me tell you I'm not very good at
being crap and doing something so I felt
a little bit awkward that was difficult
is a little firecracker
that's how feisty she is right now feel
like a fish out of water
want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips